le 19/20 continue retour à l'actualité
ça ne pouvait durer 1 6 milliard
gorbatchev justifie l'entrée en force de
l'armée rouge
au moins 57 morts à bas coût la nuit
dernière émotion et recueillement ce
matin à villeurbanne pour les obsèques
de charles hernu françois mitterrand et
de nombreuses personnalités politiques
sont venus rendre un dernier hommage à
l'ancien ministre de la défense
hérin terre ferme ses lignes au tabac à
partir du 1er mars tous les vols d'air
inter seront non fumeur une expérience
de deux mois avant une décision
définitive
enfin au rugby 29 à 19 pour le quinze de
france à cardiff c'est un véritable
exploit pour un premier match du tournoi
face au pays de galles à twickenham les
anglais ont littéralement écrasé les
irlandais 23 à 0 57 morts et plus de 300
blessés c'est le dernier bilan officiel
de l'entrée en force la nuit dernière à
bas coûts des chars de l'armée rouge les
azéri qui voulaient se retrancher dans
leur capitale font état de leur côté de
plusieurs centaines de victimes
mais l'intervention de l'armée rose n'a
pas suffi à calmer la violence des
revendications nationalistes la
république azéris du nakhitchevan a même
proclamé son indépendance du territoire
soviétique
ce matin le point sur la situation rémy
good hit celle du che mais le devoir du
gouvernement est de rétablir l'ordre à
mon profond chagrin il y a eu des
victimes
messahel gorbatchev empreint de gravité
aujourd'hui à la télévision soviétique
pour lancer un nouvel appel à la sagesse
et à la raison aux arméniens et aux
azéris cette nuit donc l'armée
soviétique a rompu le blocus de bakou la
capitale de l'azerbaïdjan aux mains des
azéri de source officielle les combats
auraient fait 57 morts et 300 blessés
mais les nationalistes azéri font état
de centaines de victimes et prétendent
que l'armée a tiré à la mitrailleuse sur
la foule
ces mêmes nationaliste affirme ce soir
que la république autonome de
nakhitchevan au sud de l'arménie s'est
prononcé à la quasi unanimité pour faire
sécession avec l'urss une déclaration
d'indépendance condamnés immédiatement
par le kremlin
plus que jamais donc les autorités
soviétiques sont confrontés à la
détermination de deux camps à bakou les
azéri n'ont cédé que militairement
devant les troupes de l'armée rouge
plusieurs milliers d'entre eux ont
d'ailleurs poursuivi aujourd'hui leur
visite sauvage en iran signe de la
détermination de la communauté musulmane
de leur côté les arméniens n'apprécie
guère l'offensive des médias iraniens
qui les décrivent comme les protégés de
moscou lasala l'armée secrète arménienne
pour la libération de l'arménie fait
justement de nouveau parler d'elle
aujourd'hui en décrivant mikhaïl
gorbatchev comme un irresponsable qui
n'a pas su empêcher l'azerbaïdjan de
déclarer la guerre au peuple arménien ce
soir le premier secrétaire d'azerbaïdjan
vient d'être remplacé par deux
responsables un azéri et un slave ce qui
semble bien peu pour faire retomber la
tension sur les bords de la mer
caspienne des personnalités nombreuses
et une foule d'anonymes
les honneurs militaires et une cérémonie
religieuse pour les obsèques ce matin à
villeurbanne de charles hernu le
président de la république est venu
rendre un dernier hommage à l'ancien
ministre de la défense met ainsi à son
ami lors d'une cérémonie pleine
d'émotion avant un enterrement dans la
plus stricte intimité
laurence piquet cérémonie religieuse
dans cette église de villeurbanne trop
petite pour accueillir les trois mille
personnes venues rendre un dernier
hommage à leur mère
accès réservé à la famille aux officiels
avec la présence de nombreuses
personnalités politiques de la région
également de nombreux élus du parti
socialiste parmi les absences remarquées
celles de laurent fabius à la demande de
madame hernu seuls les vrais amis
étaient là tels françois mitterrand qui
lors de la sphère greenpeace lui avait
écrit à l'heure de l'épreuve je suis
toujours votre ami
hommage au combat de charles hernu dans
l'homélie de monseigneur de court
trailer bonne paire amr pour qu'ils
comptaient la justice tout en demeurant
pleinement lake
il demeurait ouvert aux valeurs
spirituelles plus qu'intéressé l'éloge
funèbre a été prononcée par pierre
mauroy
après les honneurs rendus par les
détachements des armes et 8
sous-officier précédé par ces deux
militaires battant le tambour ont porté
le cercueil de charles hernu il a été
mis en terre dans l'intimité familiale
au cimetière de cusset de villeurbanne
dernier hommage de françois mitterrand à
son ami c'est charles hernu que vous
pourrez voir ce soir sur le divan
d'henri chapier à 22h15 sur l'a3 voici
quelques semaines charles hernu avait
confié cette demi-heure d'entretien qui
aujourd'hui prend une résonance toute
particulière 22h15 le divan charles
hernu aux états unis la navette columbia
est de retour sur terre après une
mission de plus de 10 jours voici les
télégrammes de l'étranger préparer et
commenté par caroline 6
voici colombien atterrissant dans le
désert du mojave en californie si la
navette a dans son ventre le plus gros
satellite jamais ramené à terre ce
satellite scientifique est resté six ans
dans le vide spatial aient recueilli dix
mille échantillons de matériaux les cinq
astronautes ont battu le record d'heures
de vol à bord d'une navette
cela fait trois ans que terry wayne est
otage au liban personne ne sait s'il est
encore vivant
teri weiss était le médiateur de
l'église anglicane au liban il a été
enlevé à beyrouth ouest par une
organisation proche du hezbollah iranien
aujourd'hui il reste trois otages
anglais et un otage irlandais à beyrouth
le parti communiste est allemand sur la
sellette violemment critiqué par ses
militants la direction se réunit pour
savoir quoi répondre
le parti va t-il se saborder non répond
déjà son président grigori ghisi ce
serait une catastrophe
mais le vice-président lui est prête à
partir ce mois ci
michel rocard et en thaïlande au
programme du jour la paix au cambodge le
premier ministre est favorable à une
solution politique et non militaire
le retour au pouvoir des khmers rouges
est exclu le 20 février une conférence à
jakarta réunir réunira les quatre
factions cambodgienne puisse la france
et l'australie en roumanie pour quelques
8000 village il était grand temps que la
révolution chasse ceausescu promis à la
systématisation des campagnes ces
villages roumains rescapés continuent
d'avoir grand besoin de l'aide de leurs
homologues français pendant des années
ça ou chez ce coût a littéralement rasé
ses villages en déportant leurs
habitants vers des centres
agro-industriel ces paysans pour la
plupart se sont retrouvés du jour au
lendemain dans d'immenses immeubles de
béton construite dans la banlieue de
bucarest
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
christophe airaud ironise jean yves p
bouda un village à 30 km de bucarest
pas une de ces soixante maisons n'a
résisté à la folie destructrice du plan
de systématisation au printemps prochain
il ne devait rien rester de ce village
300 personnes déportées pour attribuer
leur lieu de vie à l'exploitation de
terres agricoles une logique économistes
qui masquait la volonté de réduire
chaque paysan un numéro chaque habitant
à un pion suprême humiliation le régime
obliger chaque famille à démonter elle
même sa propre maison
depuis deux mois cette femme vit dans un
appentis de deux mètres sur deux mâles
aident les immigrés tous ces villageois
étaient alors déplacé relogés dans de
sinistres immeubles de béton sans aucun
confort des paysans entassés sur quatre
niveaux sans chauffage ni eau courante
dans les appartements des appartements
d'ailleurs trop exigu pour les familles
roumaines soit en avant première le
bocage by sa tête le regard soigner la
batterie que c'est une lourde affiche by
atone
le plan de systématisation a été abrogée
fin décembre mais ils sont cent mille
peut être 200 milles définitivement
déracinés personnes à l'heure actuelle
pas même le nouveau pouvoir peut
répondre à cette question simple que
faire d'eux diffusion du reportage
complet demain à 13h dans le magazine du
monde rural de l'a3 d'un soleil à
l'autre en politique française les états
généraux de l'opposition sont entrées
dans leur phase active ce week end avec
à marne la vallée
une première convention celle de
l'éducation une manière en ces temps
très agité pour l'opposition on essayait
de dépasser les querelles d'hommes pour
trouver un consensus sur les idées
philippe de ses skis il y à une
opposition qui se chamaillent et une
opposition qui travaillent c'est en ces
termes qu'alain madelin pour l'idf et
nicolas sarkozy pour le rpr ont ouvert
cette convention sur l'éducation
premier constat quand certains leaders à
droite reproche aux états-majors leurs
positions trop consensuelle force est de
constater que leur base électorale leur
donne raison
les participants de cette convention
enseignants étudiants responsables
d'associations de parents d'élèves
sympathisants de l'opposition rejette
dans l'ensemble l'idée d'une école outil
de réduction des inégalités sociales
leurs mots clés sélection
décentralisation concurrence entre les
établissements
des propositions qui ne sont pas sans
rappeler les projets de loi devaquet et
monory je vois aujourd'hui
notamment au travers des expressions des
étudiants une espèce d'adhésion général
à ce qui était la politique d' alain
devaquet qui est assez surprenante quand
on voit comment elle a été contestée il
est vrai très souvent par des gens qui
avaient une motivation politique
en 1986 la droite était coupée de la
jeunesse demain réussira-t-elle à la
convaincre une chose est sûre entre
l'opposition et la majorité
on est loin d'un consensus sur
l'éducation on s'échappe décidément très
facilement des prisons françaises après
lannemezan mende brest et quelques
autres la nuit dernière c'est de la
prison de périgueux que trois détenus se
sont évadés
mais les trois hommes sont réputés
dangereux et pourtant ils ont eu
largement le temps de prendre la fuite
sans être inquiétés leurs émotions n'a
été découverte qu'à 6h du matin
l'inspection générale des affaires
pénitentiaires est arrivé sur le terrain
dès aujourd'hui de bordeaux
jean-françois mais qu'elle les trois
hommes vraisemblablement bien équipées
se sont enfuis en douceur comme dans le
meilleur des scénarios classiques
le coût du polochon dans le lit d'abord
pour tromper la surveillance des
gardiens puis l'ouverture du plafond de
leur cellule commune du contreplaqué
puis le découpage d'un épais grillages
de sécurité
puis il gagne de toit par le chemin de
ronde avec des draps noués avant de
s'évanouir dans la nature
une évasion qui a pu matériellement se
dérouler entre 22h hier soir et 6h ce
matin
autant dire que le plan épervier
déclenché aussitôt dans tout le
département n'a rien donné
les trois détenus qui avaient
visiblement bien préparé leur affaire
ont sans doute eu le temps de rejoindre
une planque dans le milieu gitans
car il s'agit de trois gitans tous en
préventive christian vi 37 ans
originaire de blaye accusé de vol à main
armée george vi lasting charente et de
24 ans accusée de vol avec violences et
tortures en particulier sur des
personnes âgées
et puis le plus lourd si l'on peut dire
jean pierre cadiou 24 ans 1 charente est
accusé de l'assassinât en novembre 88
d'un jeune néo calédoniens lors d'une
bagarre dans un bal il devait passer
bientôt devant les assises de la
charente aux états unis depuis bientôt
deux ans tous les vols intérieurs d'une
durée de moins 2
heures sont des vols non fumeurs et bien
voici que la france à son tour déclare
la guerre à la tabagie dans les avions
et c'était un terreau qui ouvre le feu
avec une expérience qui durera deux mois
à partir du 1er mars
impossible d'allumer une cigarette sur
l'un des vols intérieurs
marie michèle martinez a jeté son paquet
ce matin avant de s'embarquer sur le
paris montpellier
mauvaise nouvelle pour les accros de la
cigarette à partir du 1er mars sur air
inter il faudra impérativement écrasé
son mégot avant de monter dans l'avion
une enquête de trois mille passagers
montre que 97% des non-fumeurs
évidemment sont d'accord pour une telle
mesure mais aussi 64 % des fumeurs
nous avons quand même voulu faire notre
propre sondage ce matin embarquement sur
le vol paris montpellier tout à fait la
corse
même si sur les vols sont bas
ne doivent pas dépasser une heure ou une
heure et quart je crois et on peut très
bien se précipiter mais pendant une
heure et quart je crois que tout le
monde peut y arriver
c'est normal de ne pas
ne pas imposer aux autres nos contrées
de nos problèmes et les produits surtout
cette décision d'air inter n'est pas une
première déjà les états unis
l'angleterre et les pays scandinaves
interdisent la cigarette sur les vols
courts aussi demandé aux pilotes de ne
pas fumer parce qu'on est dans une zone
non fumeur mais on reçoit le tabac d
de la cabine on ne peut vraiment rien
cacher à cette dame un peu de sport et
ma foi beaucoup de plaisir avec l'entrée
en fanfare du quinze de france cet après
midi dans le tournoi 29 à 19 pour les
français face aux gallois car 10 29 à 19
et 5 essais français on ne pouvait pas
espérer mieux sans fil et devenir 32e
minute d'un match très indécis
le score est de 9 partout l arbitre
expulse deuxième ligne gallois moseley
pour un geste dangereux sur andrieu mais
à 14 contre 15 les diables rouges vont
réussir à inscrire un superbe essai
parti plaide à la suite d'une erreur
d'inattention des tricolores et à la mi
temps le pays de galles mènent 13 à 9
dès le début de la seconde période
philippe sella va causer bien des
misères à l'arrière sans borne très
brillant jusque là c'est lui le plus
rapide au point de chute du ballon la
france fasse enfin en tête
le public retient son souffle l'écart
entre les deux équipes n'est que de 2
tout petit point
quand patrice lagisquet crève l'écran et
la défense adverse pour signer le plus
bel essai de la rencontre la sélection
tricolore que de nouveaux devenu
ambitieuse
il faut avoir de l'ambition que j'allais
bons mètres de là il faut battre les
arrivées a pas signé je crois que ça
sera le match phare
si sir est sélectionné d'ailleurs bon
après tout les caisses des joueurs qui
sont là sont archi archi prêt pour pour
continuer ce que la confiance est
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un policier et
tant mieux pour lequel deux fois un
quinze de france dominateur qui va
marquer un cinquième et dernier essai
par laurent rodriguez
score final 29 19 et l'angleterre en
point de mire le 3 février à paris pour
un match qui s'annonce comme le choc de
l'année
sport toujours mes côtés éprouvette
après deux ans de pénitence et à la
condition qu'ils courent toujours aussi
vite sans stéroïdes et bien ben johnson
pourra tenter de réinscrire son nom sur
les tablettes de la fédération
d'athlétisme 1 attendant son nom
justement été tout simplement gommer des
records du 100 m 50 m et 60 m la
fédération internationale d'athlétisme a
réuni cet après midi à tokyo a privé ben
johnson de tous ses records
motif bien sûr le dopage morad aït
habbouche ben johnson mise à nu le
speedy du 100 m a tout perdu cet après
midi le canadien qui avait subjuguée
fascinée stupéfait le monde du sport
avait malheureusement tricher la
dernière fois on s'en souvient dans
cette finale du 100 m des jeux
olympiques de séoul une félonie sans
précédent dans l'histoire du sprint
olympique
ben johnson avait sûrement confondues la
devise olympique situs plus vite avec
trop vite les médecins après analyses
avaient retrouvé dans ses urines du
stanozolol a produit dopant le début de
la fin devant la commission d' enquête
canadienne
il était passé aux aveux aujourd'hui à
tokyo la fédération internationale vient
d'enterrer ben johnson le sportif le
canadien n'existe plus sur leur table
est désormais l'homme le plus rapide du
monde c'est carl lewis
avec ses 9 secondes 92 réalisée le 24
septembre 88 à séoul
fini les sourires exit aussi les deux
records du monde des 50 et 60 m en salle
deux ans de pénitence pour ben johnson
mais pourra-t-il un jour se relever et
courir
plus près de nous encore des images et
les commentaires de sophie guillou
alerte aux produits toxiques ce matin
sur l'autoroute entre narbonne et
perpignan
quinze mille litres d'acide formique se
sont répandus sur la chaussée
lors d'une collision entre deux poids
lourds l'acide formique est un produit
très corrosif et dangereux à respirer il
a été neutralisé avec du sable
la circulation a pu reprendre dès le
début de l'après midi des fissures
impressionnant qui lézardent les murs
c'est une des conséquences inattendues
de la sécheresse sur certains terrains
au village de thésée dans les deux
sèvres
une centaine de maisons sont faciles
menacé d'effondrement les habitants se
sont regroupés en association
leur objectif être déclarées sinistrées
pour l'instant ils ne peuvent prétendre
à aucune indemnisation les transparents
sont devenus invisibles des
transparences ce sont des dessins de
picasso appelé ainsi parce qu'ils ont
été réalisés sur du papier calque
trois d'entre eux ont été volés hier à
marseille au musée de la vieille charité
en vol commis en plein jour par deux
hommes armés les malfaiteurs n'ont pas
visé au hasard leur butin est estimé à
plus de 3 millions de francs voilà
c'était la 1000 56e édition du 19 20 je
vous remercie vraiment de votre
attention
bonsoir bonsoir et après bien et puis
bien sûr on évoque le 19/20 bay lundi